and that would the other thing with a
big science fiction fantasy film like
this comes the joy of those conventions
like comic-con because you you all went
to comic-con fidence yes we did I had
not been to one before I never never
seen anything like it
it's absolute ordinary it's unbeliev it
really is but it's it's wonderful
there'd be to see it's just it's passion
seeing people so passionately
enthusiastic about all actually about
anything to see people motivating to
that degree to a sort of pitch of near
lunacy actually terribly moving because
the big sort of enemy in this world is
sort of apathy when people get me I
don't care but these are people who care
my god they care and the oddest thing is
is it this comic-con was sort of part of
your honeymoon
yes now you know I got a call I was on
my honeymoon and they said this is very
important you have to do you know fly in
please you have to do it and you know I
had to first explain that to my wife
which didn't play well the the whole
idea of you know spending part of your
honeymoon with people dressed up like
Captain Kirk and somehow is not easy to
explain to your to your bride your new
bride but I showed up and it was I think
you're right it was really fun because
they actually loved there they all dress
they love what they do and it's a very
passionate thing and I've never done a
film but I did one film Batman and Robin
which was a yes
[Applause]
other than that there's no reason for me
to have anything to go to commerce
didn't you apologize to the crowd at a
Comic Con for Batman or Robin
I always apologize but they say that I
actually thought I destroyed the
franchise until they brought it back you
know they'd somebody else brought it
back years later and changed it but you
know I thought at the time this was
gonna be a very good career move it
wasn't you talk about how the suit was
the enemy
well the suits brutal you know at the
time particularly it weighed like I
don't know 60 pounds and it takes you
know you have to there was a director
Joel Schumacher's very funny man very
tall very sort of eccentric and he would
direct with a speaker and a with a
microphone and a speaker usually
directors will come up and say hey yeah
yeah okay and you'd hear this from you
know booming voice and I bolted into
this suit I can't move and he would
literally go and he would direct you
like as if you would have some emotional
scene he would go okay people all right
George you know your parents are dad you
have nothing to live for
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Music]
right here is what you got to do a
little tongue thing found a bumper
sticker in the shape of a pot plan that
said [ __ ] cops